Este es el 4 problema de los 5 problemas
que nos ha mandado Cortagio,
que por cierto
me han gustado muchísimo.
Y este problema me gusta mucho porque además
de tener toda la idea del álgebra, es decir,
en este problema vamos a trabajar sistemas de ecuaciones con dos variables,
tiene un conocimiento básico de física
y no solo eso,
cuando uno lee en principio estos problemas,
parece ser que no tiene solución
y después de pensarle un rato,
uno se da cuenta que puede encontrar
una solución bastante divertida.
En este caso, vamos a leer el problema,
dice lo siguiente.
El tren A...
Oh, espera... estoy aquí en otra...
aquí está perfecto...
en otra capa...
pero ya estoy en la capa adecuada...
El tren A representado por esta flecha de verde,
ok, tiene 200 metros de largo, entonces
vamos a ponerle aquí que esto mide 200 metros...
200 metros... ok...
El tren B, representado por esta flecha,
tiene 400 metros de largo...
400...
ok, ambos corren en rieles paralelos,
a velocidades constantes,
es decir, que aunque vayan en direcciones contrarias,
nunca van a chocar,
cuando ambos se mueven a la misma
dirección, el tren A pasa al tren B en 15 segundos,
de esta configuración a esta configuración.
Y vamos a ponerlas, eso es muy importante.
Cuando empezamos en esta configuración, es decir
está primero el tren A que es justo éste, que por cierto
sabemos que mide 200 metros, ok.
Y después está el tren B,
que es este de aquí,
aquí tenemos al tren B
que mide 400 metros,
va a ser éste de aquí
y mide 400 metros, ok,
logramos pasar de esta configuración
cuando el tren A está atrás, justo atrás del tren B,
a llegar a que el tren B
quede justo atrás del tren A,
es decir el tren A alcance
y rebase al tren B, va a quedar aquí  el tren B
y aquí va a quedar mi tren A,
mi tren A que es 200 metros, ok.
Cuando pasa esto,
para pasar de esta configuración
a esta configuración se necesitan 15 segundos,
eso es muy importante,
se necesitan 15 segundos, por lo tanto,
de esta configuración a esta configuración
pasan 15 segundos...
15 segundos...
Ok, ahora dice, cuando ambos se mueven en
direcciones contrarias,
ellos se cruzan completamente en 5 segundos,
es decir, pasan de esta configuración
a esta configuración,
vamos a ponerlas.
Pasamos ahora de esta configuración,
en donde se están viendo
frente a frente,
aquí tengo el tren A que es de 200 metros,
que está viendo al tren B,
a este tren B que es de 400 metros,
400...
Oh espera, qué feo 4...
400 metros--- 400 metros, ok,
pasan de esta configuración
a una configuración en donde
aquí tengo al tren B, que es 400 metros...
400 metros y después se van a pegar,
en la parte trasera,
se van a pegar justo aquí
y ahora por aquí tengo
al tren A que mide 200 metros, ok,
y esto, esto le toma 5 segundos
en que pase de una configuración a la otra,
justo aquí dice eso, en 5 segundos
cambian de configuración,
entonces como
van en direcciones contrarias
es más rápido y esto se desarrolla
en 5 segundos...
en 5 segundos... de lujo.
¿Cuál es la velocidad de cada tren dada en m/s?
Ok, ahora, la clave de este problema...
la clave de este problema,
está en pensar lo siguiente,
pero es que si nos fijamos,
el problema dice
que se mueven a velocidades
constantes...
a velocidades constantes y eso es muy importante,
su velocidad no va a cambiar a lo largo del problema.
Y por lo tanto, si nosotros bautizamos a la
velocidad de este tren,
del tren A, como la
velocidad del tren A
originales...
y si nosotros bautizamos
a la velocidad de este tren B como
la velocidad del tren B, ok,
y vamos a ponerlo también aquí,
y aquí la velocidad del tren A...
la velocidad del tren A, de lujo.
Ahora, una vez que ya sabemos cómo se llaman
las velocidades y si nosotros recordamos la
gran fórmula que nos dice que la distancia...
y déjenmelo ponerlo con otro color...
la distancia  es lo mismo que la velocidad por el tiempo, ok,
ya que recordamos esta fórmula de la física,
entonces vamos a intentar resolver
este problema usando esta fórmula
que tengo aquí,
pero lo importante es que hablemos
y nos fijemos
en qué es lo que pasa
con las distancias relativas y con la velocidad relativa,
relativo al tren B.
Es decir que tan lejos está viajando
el tren A relativo al tren B,
si nosotros nos fijamos
por ejemplo en este punto del tren A,
si te das cuenta, lo que hace el tren A,
relativo al tren B,
es caminar esta cierta distancia,
ok, y después esta otra cierta distancia,
porque llegamos hasta la punta del tren A
y si te das cuenta,
toda esta distancia son 600 metros...
600 metros,
es decir, que si nos fijamos en
la distancia que recorre el tren A relativo al tren B,
son 600 metros
y bueno, tal vez el tren B recorra más distancia,
vaya a una cierta velocidad
y el tren B recorra, no sé,
100 metros.
Bueno, si el tren B recorre 100 metros, el
tren A va a recorrer 600
más los 100 metros que recorrió el tren B,
por lo tanto,
sigue recorriendo 600 metros
relativo al tren B.
Ahora, pensemos qué es lo que pasa aquí,
si me pongo justo aquí, justo aquí
en donde está
la parte frontal del tren A,
bueno pues yo empiezo el recorrido aquí a comparación...
más bien relativo al tren B
y acabo mi recorrido hasta acá otra vez,
hasta acá está la parte frontal de este tren A,
por lo tanto también
recorrió 600 metros,
también recorrió 600 metros el tren A, relativo al tren B.
¿Qué tan lejos ha viajado el tren A relativo al tren B?
Bueno, en ambos casos es 600 metros,
solamente
que en este caso el tren A ha empezado
su viaje, su recorrido
en la parte trasera del tren B y en este caso ha empezado su recorrido
en la parte delantera del tren B.
Ahora, en este caso la velocidad tiende a
depender de la velocidad de B,
pero es devorada
por la velocidad de B,
eso es muy importante,
porque si la velocidad de B, es por ejemplo
0, 0 m/s imagínate que la velocidad de B
fuera estática, la velocidad del tren A,
lo que hace es superar al tren B
y después recorrer estos 600 metros.
De igual manera aquí, si la velocidad del
tren B fuera 0 metros, lo que pasaría es
que el tren A
cruzaría al tren B,
ahora,  si la velocidad del tren B,
fuera cualquier velocidad que a ti se te ocurra,
el tren A siempre va
a ir más rápido, de tal manera que va a
llegar el punto en el que lo va a rebasar
y va a lograr ponerse enfrente de él, mientras que aquí va a pasar justo lo que queremos,
el tren A tiene una cierta velocidad que
va a ser más grande que la de B
y por lo tanto
en un tiempo menor, el tren A va a llegar
de esta configuración a esta configuración.
Ahora, recordando la fórmula que tenemos aquí,
la fórmula lo que nos dice,
es que la distancia,
que en este caso son 600 metros
relativo al tren B
y en este caso también son 600 metros,
es igual a la velocidad
y justo ahorita vamos a hablar de la velocidad...
por el tiempo, el tiempo
en este caso son 15 segundos
y en este caso
son 5 segundos.
Ahora, ¿qué velocidad buscamos?
Bueno, si te das cuenta,
supongamos que nosotros nos ponemos aquí,
vamos a poner aquí a un
pasajero que esté en el tren B,
supongamos que lo pongo justo aquí,
aquí tengo a un pasajero del tren B,
bueno, si me fijo en este pasajero del tren B
y relativo a él voy viendo
que velocidad toma el tren A al acercarse,
pues me voy a dar cuenta, que el tren A
al acercarse toma una velocidad de "VA",
de la velocidad del tren A
menos la velocidad del tren B.
Y bueno, esto tiene toda la lógica del mundo
porque el tren A se está acercando al tren B,
pero el tren B por otra parte se está
alejando del tren A,
por lo tanto el tren A se está acercando al tren B,
con la diferencia de velocidades.
Ok, si esto lo multiplicamos por los 15 segundos
que tengo aquí, ok, por los 15 segundos...
y bueno, esto está dado en segundos, esto
tendría que ser exactamente igual a la distancia,
que son 600 metros, ¡y qué crees!
Hemos encontrado la primera ecuación.
La diferencia de estas dos velocidades y esto
es porque el tren B se aleja del tren A,
mientras que el A se acerca al tren B, ok,
por el tiempo,
tiene que ser igual a la distancia.
Ahora, pensemos en este caso, si yo pongo
ahora a mi persona que estaba en el tren B,
lo voy a poner justo aquí, ok,
más o menos así...
y bueno, aquí parece que los brazos los tiene
alzados porque está gritando por tanta velocidad
o en dado caso los brazos
le salen de la cabeza,
pero supongamos que pongo
a mi persona relativa,
justo ahí, ok,
¿qué tan rápido se acerca
el tren A, al tren B?
Y bueno, pues el tren A se está acercando
a una velocidad de "VA", de su propia velocidad,
más la velocidad del tren B, porque si te
das cuenta, van al mismo punto,
van en sentidos contrarios,
el tren A
se está acercando al tren B
y en este caso el tren B también
se está acercando al tren A,
por lo tanto, la velocidad relativa
a esta persona que está en el tren B,
es la velocidad A más la velocidad B
y bueno,
si a esto lo multiplicamos por el tiempo,
que son 5 segundos,
déjame ponerlo,
si a esto lo multiplicamos
por el tiempo que son 5 segundos,
esto tiene que ser igual a la distancia,
que sabemos que son 600 metros...
que sabemos que son 600  metros.
Y de lujo, si te das cuenta,
aquí ya tengo, dos ecuaciones,
tengo esta ecuación de aquí,
esta ecuación de aquí, ok,
que tiene que ver con las dos velocidades
que es justo lo que busco
y esta ecuación de aquí que tiene
que ver con justo las dos velocidades que
son las que busco
y todo gracias a las velocidades relativas,
a las distancias relativas
y a estas dos personas que nos han ayudado bastante
a entender el problema.
Ahora,
¿qué te parece si resolvemos este
sistema de ecuaciones, con estas dos incógnitas?
Para eso déjame bajar
un poco la pantalla,
ok, y voy a distribuir primero, la multiplicación
de esto, es más, creo que primero voy a dividir
todo entre 15 y voy a dividir todo entre 5.
De esta parte,
¿qué pasa si divido todo entre 15?
Bueno, pues me va a quedar que "VA"...
"VA" menos "VB"
ok, la velocidad del tren A
menos la velocidad del tren B, es exactamente
lo mismo que 600 entre 15,
¿y cuánto es 600 entre 15?
Vamos a hacerlo aquí.
600 entre 15.
Bueno, pues esto es lo mismo que 4,
4 por 5 es 20, llevamos 2,
4 por 1 es 4 y 2 son 6, 60...
60 menos 60 es 0,
bajo un 0 y pongo el 0,
entonces me queda 40,
15 por 40 es 600,
por lo tanto aquí tengo 40, ok,
y de este lado...
de este lado me queda que la velocidad del tren A,
más la velocidad del tren B,
esto va a ser igual a 600 entre 5,
¿cuánto es 600 entre 5?
Bueno, pues si lo hacemos aquí, 600 entre 5
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 1...
sobra 1...
0... 2.... 10.... 0,
0 y 0... 120...
120.
Ok, ya tengo dos ecuaciones mucho más fáciles
y de hecho,
ya tengo dos ecuaciones
que se pueden sumar
y eliminamos a la variable,
la velocidad del tren B,
es decir que así pongo
"VA" más "VB" iguala 120,
estoy poniendo
las dos ecuaciones, una abajo de la otra
y la sumo,
voy a sumar ésta y voy a sumar ésta,
estos dos se van,
que es justo lo que yo quería.
Y de lujo, me queda solamente que
2 veces la velocidad del tren A,
es lo mismo que
40 más 120, lo cual son 160...
160, ok.
Y si aquí despejo la velocidad del tren A,
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 160 entre 2
lo cual es 80,
80 m/s porque recuerda que
estas son las unidades,
el tiempo está dado en segundos,
la distancia está dada en metros,
por lo tanto, la velocidad del tren A
son 80 m/s,
¡de lujo!
Ya la encontré,
que es justo lo que quería.
Ahora de aquí puedo despejar a la velocidad del tren B, de esta ecuación o de esta ecuación,
vamos a sustituirla en esta ecuación de aquí.
80 que es la velocidad del tren A...
80 m/s, más la velocidad del tren B, esto
tiene que ser igual a 120, ok,
y por lo tanto la velocidad del tren B tiene que ser igual
a 120 menos 80, lo cual son 40...
40 m/s.
Y de lujo, ya tengo ambas velocidades
que es justo lo que quería, la velocidad...
déjame ponerlo con este color...
la velocidad del tren A son 80 m/s, de lujo,
la velocidad del tren A,
mientras que la velocidad del tren B,
son 40 m/s, está de lujo,
de hecho el tren A va al doble de velocidad
que lo que va el tren B, de lujo.
Pues vamos a subir un poco la pantalla...
vamos a subir un poco la pantalla...
vamos a subirla...
Y bueno, recordando que todo esto fue gracias
a que nosotros nos fijamos en estos dos tipos,
en este tipo de aquí y en este tipo de aquí
y todo lo hicimos relativo a ellos dos,
entonces ahora podemos decir que en este primer caso,
el tren A va a una velocidad de 80 m/s, ok,
en esta dirección, mientras que
en la misma dirección va el tren B a 40...
a 40 m/s... ok...
éste no parece un 4,
déjame ver si lo puedo quitar...
ok, quitémoslo...
y vamos a poner un 4 que sí parezca 4, ok.
Y en el segundo caso...
en el segundo caso tengo que el tren A va
a una velocidad de 80 m/s,
pero en esta dirección,
mientras que el tren B va a una velocidad
de 40 m/s en esta dirección.
Y bueno, todo esto gracias a Cortagio
que nos mandó sus problemas,
que por cierto nos
han gustado bastante
y nos han mantenido bastante entretenidos.
Hasta luego.